are we like kind of putting a damn on
like some ability of our own creativity
and stuff
art is like man that's the one thing man
putting put an art in a box is like
you're keeping yourself from so many
experiences that could happen you know
yeah it's always about being like
opening yourself up a little bit and you
know sum up just being a nice good
person being kind having empathy and
create but crea do things responsibly
it's not that hard you can [ __ ] up
also you can [ __ ] up and [ __ ] fix it
and say ah [ __ ] yeah you can say you can
[ __ ] up I mean look people always talk
about on xxx sensation I brought them up
a lot in this conversation I know if you
know his music that well but he had a
terrible as a rapper that um ya know if
just if his death and he had a terrible
history with women and violence and
women and a lot people you know brought
him off for that and and I feel like
they if they want to they can't have the
right to do that but he FEX a lot of
people's lives where they just let his
music really touch people in a way that
rap hasn't done that a long time and
people like have records that had this
like Kurt Cobain feeling which is really
in raw and that people effected that way
like a little people the same thing and
I think it's okay for him to work at
himself and be better and I think the
music like I said musics about feeling
the music is something that doesn't have
to have history sometimes right a lot
people do I mean you can also define
like Michael Jackson take him off the
radio some people say like that I mean
do what you want I'm not gonna take
Michael Jackson off my myotubes I'm not
gonna stop playing his records if you
don't give people the ability to like
recognize or learn yeah or evolve or
anything at some people show me such a
king not everybody should be defined by
their history look a good example like
Malcolm X you know if you had wrote him
off like you know beating women and
going to prison and doing things and
with the prison change his life and
became a great leader and an amazing you
know philosopher in a way so the people
have a lot to offer yeah I think you
need to define like what is it that's
not right and let them know that and
like let them change and hopefully that
makes it better for other people
yeah because cancel culture it's easy to
take down celebrities but you're not
taking down the guy next to you at a bus
whatever that's actually doing damage or
like verbally abusing or a woman that's
you know right so we have to we have to
find
the waist it changed those things like
we're at words words normalized for
people in everyday culture like in a
frat or whatever it is that's gonna be
the ones to change the world not the not
just like yeah somebody's got your
moment on a it's on a Twitter or
something but yeah yeah I agree man it's
it's definitely disheartening to see
like some of the some of that culture
you know but yeah but it's but to take
it into our regular lives you know to
recognize okay well first of all what
are my own behaviors that I could be you
know like even going back to the black
lives matter movement and and just
seeing a lot of that going on you know
like it just made me think like okay
well what let me I'm really ask myself
you know if I if I'm talking to a black
person do I have different things in the
back of my head yeah while I'm talking
with them you know or if I'm if I'm with
one of my black friends a mom but hey
you know like just little things which
some of its okay some of its just nature
and it's gonna be but just make sure
just to check myself to see what's going
on you know and and we have to we have
to allow spaces where people can evening
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one